Гедімінас Ділертас поспішає на важливу ділову зустріч.
Як добратися найзручніше, він дізнається за допомогою Trafi.
Мобільний додаток через GPS визначає місце знаходження чоловіка
і пропонує список доступних поблизу видів транспорту.
Через додаток Гедімінас оплачує велосипед напрокат
так само, як і авто, яке відкриває одним дотиком на мобілці.
25-річний мешканець Вільнюса щодня користується Trafi.
Гадаю, багато людей у Вільнюсі користуються Trafi, та й не тільки тут, а у всій Литві.
Особливо популярний цей додаток серед молоді.
Створили додаток учасники стартапу в литовській столиці.
Спочатку для засновників це було радше хобі.
Юргіс Пасуконіс саме закінчив навчання в елітному технічному університеті MIT у Бостоні
та брав участь у різних конкурсах з програмування по всьому світу.
За допомогою алгоритмів спершу створили веб-сайт.
Я - технар, тому, гадаю, я не розмірковував про наслідки,
а радше завжди зосереджував увагу на технології та вирішенні цікавих завдань.
Тож чудово, що ми є співтворцями, і кожен займається окремим аспектом.
Мартинас Гудонавікіус відповідає за підприємницьку частину.
Він знайшов інвесторів та підібрав персонал.
Нині в стартапі працюють вже 45 осіб.
Роботу вони розпочали майже одночасно з Google Maps.
Сьогодні це один з їхніх найбільших клієнтів.
Програмувати інтерактивну карту з усіма транспортними засобами - зовсім не просто.
Найбільший виклик полягає в тому, щоб правильно опрацювати
та відобразити на карті сигнали GPS відповідно до того,
як рухаються транспортні засоби, та показати орієнтовний час прибуття.
На це треба багато зусиль.
Ми працюємо вже 12 років, але алгоритми доводиться постійно покращувати.
Нині їхній мобільний додаток застосовують щонайменше у 16 містах у всьому світі.
Для користувачів додаток безкоштовний.
Засновники ведуть перемовини і з німецькими містами.
Проте поки не дуже успішно.
Транспортні підприємства дуже неохоче надають дані для створення карти
та централізованого продажу квитків.
А от на батьківщині, у Вільнюсі, мер одразу підтримав ідею запровадження Trafi.
Я запроваджую у Вільнюсі найрадикальнішу політику відкритих даних
і пропагую бути відкритими для майбутнього,
більш швидкими і відкритими, ніж інші,
аби нові і часом дещо "проривні" продукти могли з'являтися на ринку.
Гадаю, важливо не протистояти майбутньому, а подружитися з ним.
У Trafi запевняють, що не  зловживають приватними даними користувачів,
суворо дотримуючись приписів ЄС із захисту даних.